[Music]
look it's finally time i mean
who knows alex jones better
than brendan chav and brian callan i
mean us i guess but who knows alex jones
better
yeah who knows alex jones better besides
everybody yeah well they have they have
a take on the trial and i wanted to
point something out to you
brendan has bullied mark hartley to be
their permanent other producer now
because they need two for this high
impact show
um
but i thought you were trying to be like
a big deal now you're a producer you
have to pick one well he's both so alex
jones was on trial he did say that okay
the attack on sandy hook was 100 real
but then now he's ordered to pay 49.3
million dollars to the families here's
what's interesting about him at the i
don't know if you guys know about it was
just
yeah close enough
almost words that's about alex jones
even when he was basically a band from
all this stuff
it still pounds platforms even then he's
making
800 000 a day
no no he wasn't i could tell you with
100
100
100 positivity that he was not making a
hundred thousand dollars a day yeah and
my fear we talked about this before this
is after youtube by the way he's saying
this is after he left youtube after he
left youtube now i am willing to believe
that there was probably
a day
where yeah made eight hundred thousand
dollars in one day in his store but he's
not making it have like they that i feel
like this is one of those things where
they they saw him do like one example of
something and they went yeah he was
doing that every day
yeah off his platform he's got a lot of
money a lot but he he you know they're
like oh because they found out that oh
you claim your bankrupt
it's different like there's mz hammer
donald trump bankrupt and alex jones
bankrupt he's like no i'm bankrupt you
can't pay this yeah but then they look
into the finances like oh bubba because
they had a forensic
economist forensic investigators and it
showed that he has like around 270 mil
yes crazy
he doesn't
that's insane
i mean he's got money i'm not saying
he's this guy that alex jones doesn't
have money but that's just a lie though
he's got enough money that when he got
the four mil
[ __ ] decision against him me and
royce were like that sucks man but you
know he'd probably be able to cover that
at some point
when they hit him with the 45 i was like
oh 39 49. so you just destroyed them
then yeah you just ruined them the face
of you know well no 49 because it was
four and then they added the 45 and i
was like well now you're just trying to
kill the man especially think about how
interested people are in all that yeah
around the world and then also think
also think about is with alex jones he's
a complicated dude right and i
you know i've met alex jones he was nice
to me i like him but if i'm one of those
parents my child was killing that dude
you i think i'm mad you'd be at him
saying it was fake this was staged these
aren't really good okay but like that's
that here's the thing
that is not
legal grounds for me to take all of your
money in your house and your life away
being wrong is not against the law yeah
we've turned we've really turned into
this weird
coddled nation of [ __ ] where now it's
like he said something that made me mad
i want all of his money fauci's covert
policies were wrong at the beginning and
people died because of them am i allowed
to suffocate and get money oh
okay
hey the people that whose whose parents
died in new york are they allowed to sue
the city of new york
why would you be allowed to do that
because their terrible decisions are why
they died sue the government oh what are
you gonna do take them to court which is
run by the government that's a good
point
i would fight him i would strangely
fight him but he would fight him okay
fine you'd punch him you know what and i
even understand i even under can i even
say this brennan i even understand that
mentality of like
i get punching somebody that's doing
that [ __ ] right i'ma [ __ ] punch you
but again it doesn't mean you get to
have him never have a job again and take
all his money those things are different
also you know 50 million dollars 49. so
what my my thing is that he he can't
afford it he he
you can
brian gallon knows
well i mean his that's in the ca he
probably just looks like his bank
accounts he just looked just logged
right in and looked at just back doored
it looks like he's got it he will afford
it i mean anyway
how we doing how much bitcoin does he
have bitcoin's running off a server in
the cia that's not true but i'm starting
that rumor let's get that going okay and
then what will happen okay and by the
way before i see in the comments that's
not how blockchain works it's a [ __ ]
joke
uh actually i was kidding
by the way royce is [ __ ] like
criminally like [ __ ] uh
uh it's stupid when it comes to like
crypto he doesn't understand like it's a
joke it's okay like you shouldn't talk
duh but you shouldn't talk about things
that you don't understand
because you know hey man andrew andrew
tate son caleb thanks i'm watching
andrew tate thank you happiness where i
get all my information from he'll go on
to become even bigger i don't know if
he's bigger that might be the height i
don't know if he's bigger because
clearly he lied on the stand he purged
himself you can see it did you see that
yeah did you see that you gave us two
years your lawyer gave us two years but
did you see the lawyer [ __ ] up and
accidentally sent this i'm saying that's
what he just said
brennan but did you instead of you see
how he repeated what brian said yeah
instead of you just talking over me if
you were to let me
if i could just get one
dude he does that though to everybody
it's like stop yeah
yeah two years yes
two years they can use yeah to the other
lawyers yeah that's physician purpose no
on accident on purpose
i'm sorry but there's no way in the
world by the way shut up mark harley
stop saying on accident it's by accident
okay okay it was this was done 100 on
purpose this wasn't an accident looks it
looks on purpose i i got skeptics
when i read them like oh thank thank you
right clearly it looks like the lord
somebody did alex jones
can one of you talk and then the other
one talks and then the other one talks
and then the other one talks yeah
honestly if i wanted to hear this stuff
i would go i want to [ __ ] pass these
friday night streams
or someone paid them off easily yeah
there's like multiple charts so this is
like one of them there's he has like
three more or something has to go in
court with so who knows how much he's
going to owe in the very end what's
weird is that so i don't mean yeah no
yes
oh my god
i don't mean to do it
but i don't know he is interrupting him
it's actually happening right now he's
interrupting him
it's like every time he talks
hey mark call crystalia i'm out of here
get will sasso in here okay
i'll call theo vaughn
dude can mark harley please get brian
calan on steroids so that brian kellen
[ __ ] snaps on brendan sharp one day
stop [ __ ] interrupting me he starts
punching holes in those plasterboard
walls
he's gonna punch a hole where you can
see through to the trash tuesday's
podcast
the other side of it and they're doing
it so anyway that guy was so cute
and you just see esther's face pop and
go wow
wow that's crazy
and annie letterman's like oh no toxic
masculinity am i right
i used to [ __ ] kurt metzger and then
anthony just was like that north
mcdonald's a real piece of [ __ ]
untalented hack yeah now that it's safe
yeah he is definitely dead though right
okay yeah i never liked that guy
obviously rogan defends alex jones but
rowan does obviously rogan defends alex
jones say yeah he made a mistake he
makes a lot of mistakes he's a lot of
things right he's like that's the
problem a broken clock is right twice a
day
wow that's brilliant that's a good first
off alex a broken clock would imply that
alex jones has only been right twice
alex from jones has been right more than
two times
brian and now
that's a very good point what a stupid
dumb old analogy huh
right you could that's that's what i
would be doing
like he was talking but yeah yes and no
right because if you're not yes or no a
book and raw
a broken clock is right twice a day
it's not yes and no there's not yes and
no to that
it is that's the way it works
you're saying you know
with his stuff like he was talking about
epstein island
10 years ago he's like oh there's an
island where they go and they have
famous people go there they compromise
and have hooked up with underage girls
and it's like you're out of your mind
that that's that's probably true right
can you see if you could find that not
on youtube
yeah if i go to band.tv i'll find it
well that's true no i'm telling you yeah
rogan brought it up rogan goes you need
to have someone create a clip of all the
[ __ ] you got right for throughout all
the people have done that and then they
get banned from social media for sharing
it because people like you think he
shouldn't be allowed to talk i will clip
i'll clip something for the show like
for example i mean in front of brenda
shop whatever it does the clip is really
well any time i clip an alex jones thing
it's nobody sees it it's completely
shadow banner does not pop up anybody's
thing it just doesn't show up nope
the year yeah because he's like you've
got more right than you've gotten wrong
but the stuff he's gotten wrong he's
gotten wrong wrong no that's that's
interesting i i i do think that that's
probably one of the reasons he's so
[ __ ] successful
uh because oh there wouldn't be if he if
he was wrong all the time he could only
be wrong swinging wrong
in his voice when he said he's so
[ __ ] successful
well yeah i know and they're mad and
here's what i'm saying here look this is
my analysis i could be wrong and you
guys tell me viewers is different but
what i'm seeing here here is two guys
that actually want to rip into alex
jones but are not doing it because alex
jones's friend was friends with rogan
that's what that's the vibe
by the way i don't i don't even think
shops so much honestly to shop's credit
i don't even
know is where i'm getting that vibe from
the most right
yeah
yeah
no he's got
some very strong followers and i'm not i
i i have to be careful about criticizing
his pants wait this is he's dressed like
one of those [ __ ] hobo like turn of
the century clowns oh god yeah you're
right
was it picasso that painted clowns for a
while yeah he looks like a picasso clown
sad clown those are picasso clown pants
i [ __ ] hate him so much that's the
way a clown would dress in a cirque du
soleil show
like one of those hobo clowns
an old sad french clown i am just a
merchant from this town
and you're about as funny as an old sad
french clown yeah seriously so it works
we're out dude no he's got some very
strong followers and i'm not i
i have to be careful about criticizing
because i don't know enough about what i
don't follow i like alex jones i hate
this his sandy hook that's the thing
that's that's what that's what's that
kid what a maverick
that's right so those parents i'm like
yeah pay them yeah but then
yeah with those parents yeah
pay them no
you absolute here's the problem
it's the implications on freedom of
speech and what you're allowed to say
which are not to be right i'm not saying
that alex jones was right about sandy
hook not at all
but what i am saying is that he should
be allowed to be wrong about sandy hook
without having to pay 49 million dollars
that parents are like yeah pay them yeah
but then go back to work yeah because i
like his work someone you notice
something then go back to work okay 49
million he's got that on i'm sure that's
what you believe but here's the other
thing
you want to notice something funny
you notice that remember that guy that
went into the comet ping pong pizza that
was going to shoot the place up and all
that stuff you kind of noticed that
story kind of came and went real fast
and then they kind of let it go and
there wasn't an international incident
like the sandy hook thing but you think
they'd want to milk that one right but
the problem is is that
do you really want people looking into
that one do you really want people to
look at you you mean the do you mean the
shooting where the guy walked into comet
ping pong and one bullet went off and it
didn't hit anybody but it did somehow
miraculously hit a hard drive in the
computer that was in the office
that's weird
that is yeah
really strange that one
but again we don't want to look into
that one well it's interesting that's
where i like the ghost
he lost i think you need to i think you
need people like shows i think you need
outliers i think people that push
against the french i think he's great
but you also think you should play 49
million dollars for being wrong yeah i
think we should have people like this
but i also think that we should take
their livelihoods away so we never have
people like this
and you're the face of it of course he's
making money i feel like he's
entertaining i just think that people
who lend a voice to misinformation and
mal information and disinformation are
the problem yeah of course cia brian
cia brian
callan
misinformation who lend their platform
to misinformation
you are the victim of misinformation you
were
somebody accused you of [ __ ] rape
all right man so why don't you just
[ __ ] relax
a little bit brian and become a little
bit more aware
understand that it always starts with
people like alex jones and before you
know it something you said 10 years ago
is going to come and bite you on the ass
right and then you're going to go oh man
this is so [ __ ] up but i'm not alex
jones yeah when i bet when they ban alex
off every platform it was just alex
jones it may be andrew angling before
him but that's about it right
and
af everyone was like yeah but he's a
piece of [ __ ] but he sucks and then they
started [ __ ] banning normies and
[ __ ] people that were just posting
kind of spicy memes but nothing bad
because that's where it goes because
nobody ever fights when they start this
nobody ever fights because it's easy to
say get rid of alex jones and now you
can't even say the word laptop on
twitter no what if i'm trying to sell a
laptop